we're over here at our partner dreams
booth and they got some amazing
Innovative Tech going on first of all I
want to show you the x30 ultra Robot
vacuum it comes with a lot of new
features like mop extend which you can
actually put the mop under Furniture has
navigation 8,200 pas of suction power
automatic self-cleaning base station
that vacuums up the dust out of the
vacuum itself now over here we have
their A1 robotic mower I'm really
excited to try this out it works with
self-navigation self scanning and
basically every day it's going to be
cutting a little bit of your grass off
to keep it nice and trimmed and then
right over here we have all of their
stick vacuums we have the dream R20
which is battery powered with high
suction but the thing I really want to
try out is the h13 pro this is a wet and
dry vacuum that really takes the pain
out of vacuuming and mopping your floors
so huge thank you to dream for
sponsoring this video we love your Tech
and we're excited to work with you on
future collaborations